so I want to end just just with this I
want to show you a picture because I
found this picture and if I found it
very poignant and I'm sure you will too
you probably remember the picture this
is a picture on a boat and this is 1962.
and there are two people in that picture
this is the TSS Fair Sky it was a Sit
Mile Line boat
tell me who's in that picture well it's
my mum sitting there on the uh Marriott
as I said Marianne on the the far right
she's next to her brother
George
and uh standing up in in white is a a
dashing fellow who happens to be my
father Carlo who was a person on the
ship
that my mother traveled to on that long
journey to England to England here where
she lived in London for a while and she
felt pregnant she did she had a
relationship with Carlo and during I
think not just on the ship but clearly
from piecing it together
when he
quite likely that's right so you're
actually you're one of us and when you
visit you're English right I'm still not
going for you in the ashes so don't try
that don't try that on but you accept
you could have been conceived that's not
going to happen I think I think chances
are I was yeah I think I was here uh
when the ship used to birth at
Southampton and uh my mum uh
traveled met him had a relationship uh
with him uh fell pregnant
he was uh in she when she told him he
was engaged to uh
the person who became his wife back in
Italy and so she went back to Australia
had me made the courageous decision in
1963 to be a single mother and to to
raise me she was very Catholic so it was
a difficult thing for the family and at
that time she was Odes to have you
adopted she she was and that was what
was very common your life could have
been so different it would have been
very different and at the time it was to
be that I had been I would be adopted
out and that the story would be told in
the local community and in the family
that she had got news of my father's
death and that had caused her to the
trauma to lose her child but she
couldn't do that I was there was a
moment where a nun at the hospital knew
that she was the sort of person who
didn't she just really didn't want that
to happen she was under a bit of
pressure so she brought me into my mum
and my mom was never going to let me go
what a moment it I mean us sliding doors
oh absolutely but incomparable enormous
consequence oh and she then adopted his
name Albanese but continued to to
pretend that he had died in an accident
that's right and I was told to you yeah
I was told that until I was old enough
when she felt I could understand you
were 14 that's 14 15. uh you know and
how did you feel when you found out he's
potentially still alive oh I at the time
I mean I was a pretty tough young kid we
had a we had a difficult upbringing I
mean my mum I had rheumatoid arthritis
and was crippled up was an envelope
pensioner we lived in a council house
where she had lived her whole life my
grandparents had died by then so it was
just me and Mum we didn't have anything
economically but I had her unconditional
love and that was enough for me and so I
said I'm not interested
uh you know that's you're enough for me
which is what she needed to hear so
while she was alive I didn't search for
him but she died in 2000 and uh two my
son had come along uh in 2000 and there
was a moment where I was at her
gravesite and my little boy was very
little said you know where's your daddy
and I sort of realized that yeah I
needed to and he had a right to ex here
understand uh what had happened and so I
I had I guess once she passed away I
could then search for
him without uh bringing any
uh sense that she wasn't all I needed
and so I found him uh in 2000. it's an
amazing story because this is nearly 40
years later yeah 46 years later
incredible I was 46 when uh when we met
right by pure chance a friend of yours
is now running the ship company that had
been renamed several times it was now
three Carnival Cruises you knew this
woman and she helped the search and they
find your dad's old employment private
details in some dusty rickety area in
Genoa where the original ship stuff had
all been sent yeah and from that you
were able
by now you're you're a minister right
under their trials a minister in the
government
and you're able to track down your dad
and you're in a meeting or you're in
your office I think and it's a Thursday
and you get a call from this friend of
yours he's running the the ship company
and she just says
we found him it was it was a remarkable
moment and I was chairing a a Ministry
or council meeting of all the state and
territory ministers an important meeting
that night
and I told my stuff to go on without me
and I just took I took my breath away it
was an extraordinary moment emotional
friend oh it was incredibly emotional
did you shut a tear and then oh
absolutely it was it was uh I didn't
realize
just how significant it was because I
think it is everyone everyone's
different
and relationships are complex as my life
story shows but for me that sense of
identity and belonging
was important you know I had this name
Al benazi and I had said where's your
when asked and I represent a big Italian
constituency as well in Sydney so when I
was asked I would say Naples because
that's where the ship sailed from but in
the end it was uh pullia the other side
of of Italy six weeks later
you you're there yeah and the door opens
and then walks your dad this is 46 years
later yeah I we had a we wrote to him uh
and uh wrote a careful letter just
saying that my my mother Mary Ellery was
known to him and that I would be
visiting Italy I was visiting the
European transport minister at the time
uh tayani was based in was an Italian so
I had a meeting with him scheduled so I
I wrote and said I'll be here you know
on this Day on on this weekend and so I
met with they had an intermediary they
were wondering what was going on here I
guess had an intermediary I told her the
story
and she I said I don't want anything
else anything out of him uh I would like
to meet him I think he's my father
and so I didn't know what to expect and
then the the very next morning I had a
very short window of opportunity because
I had a full schedule I was on my way to
London as well to speak at the
international Maritime organization here
the big conference and uh and he walked
I didn't know what to expect and he just
embraced me and what a moment that was
quite extraordinary how did you feel
hugging your dad that you thought was
dead until you were 14. it was an
incredible moment and and not just him
but uh my half brother and half-sister
came with him and so I I went from
having a a very small family to having a
much larger one and it just gave me that
sense of completeness and and I was I
was very lucky because he passed away in
January of 2014 so we were able to meet
on a few occasions I traveled to Italy I
brought back it was a short meeting so I
brought back my son to meet his
grandfather in the following Easter so
in Easter of
2010 and would any of this happen if
your boy hadn't said what he'd said at
your mum's gravesite quite possibly not
or if uh I someone at Carnival Cruises
happened to be someone I didn't have
done a little and if she hadn't have
known a historian who lives in
Wollongong who who knew where to look
and had found this box of papers
essentially employment files in a port
incredible were you able to be there
when your father died or not I went to
uh I went to visit him in 2013 in
December we lost the election in 2013
but then I'd become Deputy Prime
Minister before we we lost that that
election lost government he wasn't well
so I I went to see him uh I knew that he
was he was dying he was at home in his
family flat there in poulia and when you
were saying goodbye
to each other and that the last thing
that he said to me was that he was glad
that he'd found me
amazing
it was uh quite quite a journey from uh
that beginning to be Australian prime
minister so it's a great deal about our
country it's ahead of us think what
would they have made of you becoming
prime minister your parents
um well my my mum would have uh
shed a tear perhaps each and every day I
remember my first speech she she was
there up in the uh the gallery and I
couldn't look up because if I had of I
would have been hopeless as well she was
incredibly proud and I see what I do
as you know her treatment without her
and that unconditional love of a parent
for their their child which which she
gave me you know she did it really tough
she had she really wasn't very well when
she died she was only 65 years old and
she was spent really at the at the end
of what is she a native Journey today
you'll go and see the king
oh she would have happened you know she
would have been having skipped the
journey to hospital diverted with you
Insider uh to see the queen I mean what
an amazing
Journey that has been oh look she would
she would have been uh wrapped by all of
it and uh she would have been very proud
and I I I still think that you know
she's she's looking down on me and uh
she's still with me uh each and every
day because the values that I have
uh the values uh that she gave me and I
say I was raised with three great Fates
to go back to Russell Crowe being one of
them the Catholic Church uh South Sydney
football club and the Australian labor
party and uh they're the values that I
have and that that I hold very dear
prime minister it's been a real pleasure
what an extraordinary story uh your
story is and thank you for sharing it
with me yeah thanks very much good luck
with my king when are you going to see
him indeed I'll I'll say g'day to him
please do great to see you good on you
thank you